they say once you get married you stop
having sex I was like oh man
have I been married this whole time was
I born married I didn't even get a
toaster I'm not good at dating my
longest relationship was nine months
yeah my mom carried full-term
thank you that jokes all about delivery
my roommate suggested that I join a gym
to meet women yeah cuz that's where I'm
at my most impressive the gym hi nice to
meet you you want to spot me while I try
to open the gym door just going for two
reps in and out trying to get in better
shape my future goal is pill to
benchpress my body weight my current
goal is get down to 45 pounds
I tried to eat healthy for like a minute
I thought I really liked trail mix
turns out I just liked M&Ms that play
hard-to-get it's just to throw the chase
I'm like in a rush to get in better
shape though because I have my 10-year
high school reunion coming up pretty
soon and I was in bands you know I want
to make sure I can still fit my old
Locker I used to get picked on quite a
bit in school these kids used to make
fun of my friend Scott and I by singing
this song Matt and Scott sitting in a
tree kis s ing first comes love then
comes marriage then comes baby in the
baby carriage and it used to make me
really upset but now I understand I just
didn't realize how progressive my
bullies are
gay marriage gay adoption they are way
ahead of their time I got run over by a
stretch limo took forever I'll address
it so I can tell something you can't
stop thinking about it I have posed nude
for an art class it's actually how I
lost my job substitute teaching and I am
legally obligated to tell you that joke
I feel bad for Eskimos on acid because
they can't tell if their walls are
really melting anyway I've dated all
kinds of women as far as you know I am
my ex-girlfriend
you know how some guys like it doggy
style my ex-girlfriend she liked it cat
style that sir she'd just ignore me for
weeks on end
and then take my closet through this
like weird online dating thing I ended
up sleeping with my third cousin I can't
believe I've had sex with three of my
cousins
maybe I shouldn't have been using
ancestry.com I have a girlfriend now
we're not related and she's great but we
fight sometimes like lately we've been
going back and forth on whether or not
we want kids and it's been really hard
on our son
my girlfriend she does got some for her
pleasure condoms and I had never seen
these before there were all these little
bumps on the outside and the inside had
another man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you